this video is epic so we're back again
with more among us as you see on the
screen we got lots of famous youtubers
this will be epic let's jump right into
the first game
wham bam thank you ma'am give me
impostor bro i want to murder god
all right imposter detective
detective beam on the case here oh
sussed them all out mate oh no
everyone's dispersing i need a buddy
i'll choose dream dream can be my buddy
give me the new keys kind of
because these guys are so big brain
watch it here's the button because i
forgot to check if i had a key and i
just ran straight down i want to be
alone
okay you want to kill me kill me just
kill me jimmy get away from me look at
that boy running with that paper trying
to figure out who the bad guy is again i
swear this is always my responsibility
you be doing what i'll be sussing you
out actually you know the fact that
nobody called me there makes me think
it's one of the big brain boys we're
gonna not do any more tests we're gonna
run around looking for dead bodies i'm
all alone this is bad this is bad
where's dreamy why am i doing tasks i
literally just said i don't do tasks
maybe i'm a changed man maybe i'm going
through a different path in life
that's a fence okay
george is trying to run into the fans
i don't know what i just did but i did
it oh hey trailer chris hey chris yeah
let's go taylor stick with me chandler
and chris in communications
they seem to be standing on top of each
other a little bit weird chandler
they're flickering the lights all right
i'm turning the water chris watch my
back chandler come on let's go we got to
do the lights chiller laser tried to
kill me i thought they're gonna murder
each other i just i just didn't want to
leave him alone are we friends i think
we're friends i gotta do it
done he was daring me
why he was literally daring me i could
not do it
i thought we were friends what is wrong
with him that's not just came out of
specimen room there's nobody in specimen
jimmy did you get the kill jimmy
joey did you
yeah you did ram's gonna walk in on the
body
there it is
yeah who found the body there's two
people in uh lab and then there was uh
one person in the lab and i was like
they're still there it's been a while i
walked to vitals i saw george was dead i
walked to lab and i found his body he
knows he knows just sorry i can clear
chris and chandler for that because we
were all sort of on top of each other
did anyone else see that jimmy didn't do
keys what's that jimmy keys is the task
at the top he didn't he didn't that's
enough for me he was the only person
actually
carl defending jimmy too i didn't defend
jimmy i just told him where the task was
i mean it's enough for me he didn't do
keys and it could have been him for this
kill so hey i understand if you vote me
i just want you to know i'm not an
imposter but i understand yeah save the
crap buddy you're good
just save it save it
out here get him out of here
settle down settle down i just want to
let all of you know that i literally saw
dream killed george goodbye oh my god
okay no now it's 100 if it ain't bass
it's dream and sad yeah good riddance
get him out of here mr base is dead i
did what i could carl carried the torch
jimmy why did you screw me over he saves
that for the last second he's salty oh
lights are off oh no i'm gonna fix these
lats real quick look at my puppy all sad
now that i'm dead
who is the other person i reckon it's
sad i think it's dream i think it's
dream i'm going to sit right here on top
of a dream boys this might be my first
ever l as an imposter oh that's more
now i have my proof where'd my boy go
where'd my boy go where is chandler is
he dead chandler
i just told him i was scared i'm not
gonna vote but i'm such a dream no i was
doing tasks the entire time you can ask
zap that i'm pretty sure dream is safe
because i've been watching him dream if
you confirm sapp i confirmed you and
then carl's confirmed chris is confirmed
it could be laser but nobody died
chandler nobody died look we know
nothing except i don't think it's dream
because he pushed for beasts
carl is playing this very well i'm proud
of you carl keep my win streak alive i
really need to split kill somebody i'm
just going to stand beside dream the
entire time i reckon it's sad man oh my
god just kill someone we know it's you
sap meanwhile dream
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
i bet you they're all freaking together
right now they're trying to be carl
they're trying to be cold i keep trying
to leave the room and come back and
hoping sapp's killed someone because
it's 100 him it's no doubt in my mind
okay
i'm not allowed to swear on a mr bass
video i'm sorry i might have been the
worst kill worst call i could have done
calling button they're not even going to
find my body bro laser's dead where is
he at carl threw me i think it's carl
chris and i think carl's playing a big
brain here i'm i've confirmed snap now
chris saw it go up did you not did i saw
the task bar going you and sapnap didn't
do the task chris didn't do the task
chandler said he wasn't doing a task and
laser said he wasn't doing a task oh my
god carl might do it how am i doing
we're not a hundred percent on that okay
i'm suss of you you could be trying to
use this as a ploy okay
they all said they were gonna stick
together and carl's just run off on his
own i actually kind of want kyle to get
away with it he might have stabbed me in
the back but i still want to see him win
jimmy you gave me nothing to work with
dog i don't know what i'm supposed to do
wait bar's gonna go up a lot that's the
confirmation on him ah it's carl oh it
went up no it's not chandler now yeah
prove it baby it's carl carl's the
imposter carl's the impostor i'll call
the button
everyone else was watching chandler for
a campy chandler i saw chris do a node
task it's carl carl's the imposter car
rolls the imposter carl you're supposed
to carry the torch you gave me nothing
to work with jimmy what on earth was i
supposed to do with that jimmy let's go
yeah
where are you carl
all right
cauldron go go go will i die first or
will i survive i'm gonna do garbage i
never get imposter i'm a little nerd on
this map i'm really good at this map i
have my suspicions about chris oh no
look at my electrical oh my god
you've got chris heading back into the
middle cafeteria hey dream it's me
george you are my friend you will not
kill me i hate this test
and that's one key swipe and ready to go
they're gonna think i'm an imposter
because i can't do it mr beast is on
card swipe for mighty long
how do you do this now get time to do my
electrical task or will i die
how
okay uh jimmy dude how do you do this
card swipe i can't do it yeah yeah yeah
what happened jimmy was on card swipe
for like 45 seconds i can't figure it
out nah this task actually sucks i'm
gonna give him credit for that everyone
follow me back to card swipe just follow
and watch no one do a single test 45
seconds though that's that's such a long
time how do you do it you do like medium
speed it just has to be steady you've
got to be even with it too you gotta go
up and down shut up everybody you're not
helpful dream come back and watch me do
it okay i will my luck i wouldn't be
able to swipe a stupid card and they
think i'm an imposter let's see it mr
beast let's see this console
how do you do this
i can't there's no way it's taking him
this long i'm just gonna leave the room
i want him i want him to be able to get
off that and then go be impostor three
hours later
i got it don't kill me in electrical oh
george don't kill me don't kill me don't
kill me don't kill me it's mr beast it's
mr beast it's mr beast
i just wanted to update you i finally
figured out the card swipe okay we can
skip did anyone see him though didn't
see him do it i didn't see it i was
there you literally saw it i saw him do
it all right so why'd you call the
meetings out there because i thought i
didn't see him do it what i finally got
it kind of set the laser we said no one
do attacks and laser went on there was
doing it like maybe to make him more sus
if i was in poster dream you would be
dead nobody's gotten killed yet guys why
are we all so sons whoever's the
imposter kills somebody i'm tired of
hearing so many people
all right now we gotta kill chandler or
chris probably chris doing my wire test
wiring wires
carl's just dancing don't don't kill him
don't kill me don't kill me don't kill
me i'm not actually on cameras someone's
on the cameras carl don't kill me carl
don't kill me why is everyone i haven't
seen anyone this entire round if i die
here and i tried to do this test three
times i will slam my keyboard
[Music]
no no no no no no i press report
i pressed report streaming god's car if
i find dream's body it's laser if drew's
body's in here it is laser
oh there was a double kill electrical
electrical dad dream i hate your
minecraft speedrun staff map who are you
with in uh in security wait i actually
do i don't know if it's a double kill
how many did you see there there's one
body in electrical coral kill laser and
electrical channels got it figured out
so why'd you say it was dope killed and
now say it's not i don't know i just got
confused that is kind of sucks no i hey
guys i've been since the beginning
because i literally finally did the car
task after a minute straight and this
dude right there beside me is like oh he
didn't do it dream you're gonna lose
it's not me i'm voting sapnab i'm voting
sapna it's not me dreams it's dreams
no no no no no it's not that listen
you're not this dumb colin chandler who
are you voting for it's carl goss oh we
just lost
no i think you killed two people and
tried to pretend like it was a double
kill yeah you try to pretend like it was
double kill by killing two people all
right it's carl and dreams dreams
defending carl it's carl and dream they
think they're so smart it's carl and
dream two imposters on an eight person
lobby is so hard if they know what
they're doing no one listens to chandler
we just can't lose no no no okay
i trust kyle let's go get one kill on
this game over i'm surely they know this
it's definitely carl and george it's
carl and george girl's got it
i knew it no one listens to me literally
no one
your brains are smooth i hope you gamers
enjoyed if you want more among us let us
know and if you're not subscribed do it
now explosion